bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne
la séance de questions cribles
thématiques consacrées aujourd'hui à
l'hébergement d'urgence
cette séance intervient alors que le
gouvernement a présenté mardi son plan
de lutte contre la pauvreté qui prévoit
d'ailleurs la création de 8000 places
d'hébergement supplémentaires à la fois
pour les personnes sans domicile fixe
mais aussi pour les demandeurs d'asile
cécile duflot la ministre du logement
qui vient répondre aux questions des
sénateurs
cécile duflot qui avait suscité la
polémique par ses propos début décembre
la ministre a en effet demandé à
l'archevêché de paris est bien de mettre
à disposition des sans domicile ses
locaux vides
des propos qui avaient fortement agacé
la communauté catholique tout de suite
donc direction l'hémicycle pour suivre
cette séance bon après midi à tous la
séance s'est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions cribles
thématiques sur l'hébergement d'urgence
alors je rappelle que l'auteur de la
question et le ministre pour sa réponse
disposent chacun de deux minutes
une réplique d'une durée d'une minute au
maximum peut être représenté soit par
l'auteur de la question soit par l'un
des membres de son groupe
je rappelle aussi que ce débat est
retransmis en direct sur la chaîne
publique public sénat et sur france 3 et
il importe que chacun des orateurs
bien entendu cette fois encore respecte
son temps de parole pour la première
question
la parole est à monsieur alain bertrand
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre est
meilleurs collègues selon le dernier
baromètre du 5,15 dévoilé mercredi 16
décembre la prise en charge des sans
abri s'est encore détériorée depuis un
an dans les 37 départements observer les
demandes d'hébergement
ont augmenté de 37% par rapport à
novembre 2011
le dispositif ne parviennent donc plus à
répondre aux demandes
le taux de réponses négatives atteignent
70 % ce qui est extrêmement élevé cette
tradition a fait que les territoires
jusque là épargné plus fac par encore
l'augmentation du nombre de familles à
plantes et de jeunes les familles
représente désormais 53 % des demandes
avance de 60 % sur une seule année
monsieur le premier ministre a annoncé
mardi lors de la clôture de la
conférence de lutte contre la pauvreté
la création de 8000 nouvelles places
d'hébergement en plus de moyens
supplémentaires accordés pour 2012 qui
seront consolidées en 2013 le plan
hivernal a été mise en oeuvre de manière
anticipée accélérer ses biens vous avez
aussi évoqué la possibilité de
réquisitionner un certain nombre de
bâtiments la réquisition fait certes
partie de la panoplie légal mais ne nous
trompons pas de cible madame la ministre
la responsabilité de l'hébergement
d'urgence revient avant tout et quelles
que soient les conditions à l'état
madame la ministre je vous poserai une
question qui pourrait paraître décalé
mais qui ne l'est pas ce début de grand
froid puisqu'il s'agit de l'absence
forte de réponse annuel et non pas
simplement en hiver
l'hébergement d'urgence n'est pas une
affaire de saison aujourd'hui on est
dans une gestion au thermomètre
le stop and go qui remet à la rue dès
que les températures sont plus clémentes
pour ta main juillet les demandes au 115
ont été aussi importante 4 décembre et
mars mais au moins abouti du fait
notamment de la fermeture des places
hivernales
d'où la question du groupe rdse et ma
question comptez vous que comptez-vous
faire un sur la gestion annuels étaient
hiver annuel à les douze mois de l'année
de l'hébergement d'urgence samu
ministre merci madame cécile duflot
ministre d'égalité des territoires et du
logement
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur bertrand mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
vous pointez dans votre question
monsieur le sénateur deux éléments
absolument essentiel le premier c'est
que l'aggravation de la crise rend
encore plus difficile la situation du
mal logement et à jeter y compris des
familles ces derniers mois à la rue et
un deuxième élément qui est absolument
essentiel c'est que le plan hiver n'est
pas un plan satisfaisant parce qu'on
meurt plus à la rue en été qu'en hiver
et parce que les besoins sont tout aussi
criant en été qu'en hiver voilà pourquoi
le gouvernement a décidé et vous avez
fait référence aux annonces du premier
ministre de sortir de la logique du
thermomètre de mettre en place un
dispositif pérenne d'hébergement
pérennes veut dire aussi par l'ouverture
de centres parfaitement adapté avec
l'ouverture également deux places de
logements accompagnés 8000 places
supplémentaires en plus des 1000 places
déjà annoncé au titre du budget 2013
pour l'hébergement 9000 nouvelles places
de logements accompagnés pour favoriser
aussi l'accession au logement
traditionnel et pour sortir
définitivement de la logique du
thermomètre
j'espère que nous mettons en oeuvre pour
la dernière fois le plan grand froid
c'est à dire l'ouverture de gymnase de
lieux pas vraiment adapté et que nous
aurons aussi le moyen de répondre aux
besoins des familles il ya aujourd'hui
des familles qui se cache parce que
quand des enfants sont à la rue et pour
maintenir le contact avec eux les
parents se cache donc il est parfois
difficile de les identifier mais nous
avons la responsabilité de mettre en
oeuvre cette politique vous avez avec
raison dit qu'il était de la
responsabilité de l'état
et c'est parce qu'il est de la
responsabilité de l'état que pour
certaines agglomérations je pense en
particulier à l'agglomération
francilienne à la région rhône-alpes ou
à celle de provence alpes côte d'azur
le gouvernement a décidé de pouvoir
faire appel à la réquisition de
bâtiments vides justement pour assurer
sa responsabilité qui est de trouver les
lieux d'accueil pour des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui à la rue nous aurons
effectivement l'occasion d'en débattre
mais je tiens à vous dire que sur les
deux points de votre question monsieur
le sénateur le gouvernement a décidé de
mettre en oeuvre une politique
d'hébergement différentes qui s'appuie
sur un principe fondamental le droit à
un toit
merci madame la ministre je pense que
notre
le gadin bertrand 20 intervenir monsieur
le président a juste pour dire que la
réponse de la ministre me convient
parfaitement et qu'elle convienne à mon
groupe
une action plus annuelle plus forte
c'est ce que nous demandons à ces
contenus manifestement dans la stratégie
de marine ministre de sa réponse merci
très bien merci nous pouvons passer à la
deuxième question d'apprendre l'état
madame elisabeth lamure pour le groupe
le me paie union pour un mouvement
populaire merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
nous avions tous constaté avant même
l'arrivée des grands froids que trop de
personnes relevant du 115 rester à la
rue chaque soir est d'ailleurs j'avais
indiqué en novembre en commission des
affaires économiques qu'à lyon plus de
700 personnes n'avaient pu trouver
d'hébergement est passé la nuit dehors
alors que l'hiver n'était pas encore
installé dans cette situation dramatique
est due à l'insuffisance du nombre de
places disponibles on regarde la demande
certes mais également à l'incohérence
actuelle de la réglementation qui
pourtant partait d'intentions louables
en effet la loi du 5 mars 2007
instituant le dalo a introduit le
principe de continuité de prise en
charge entre l'urgence et l'insertion et
la loi de mobilisation pour le logement
et la lutte contre l'exclusion du 25
mars 2009 a introduit un droit à
l'accompagnement personnalisé pour les
personnes or ces dispositifs ont montré
leurs limites les contrats d'insertion
par lesquels les personnes accueillies
s'engageait dans la voie de l'insertion
sociale sont devenus sans effet du fait
de l'absence de sanction qui se limite à
une exclusion très temporaire par
ailleurs cette réforme a pour
conséquence de maintenir en longue durée
dans les centres d'hébergement des
personnes pour lesquelles aucune
solution pérenne et adapté n'existe et
donc ces personnes occupent les places
d'urgence aux dépens de personnes à la
rue en plus grande difficulté
humanitaire par ailleurs le principe de
continuité de l'hébergement apporte une
regrettable confusion entre la notion
d'hébergement qui signifie un court
séjour répondant à des objectifs
humanitaires et la notion de logement
qui elle s'inscrit dans la durée enfin
la confusion entre hébergement
et logement s'étend aux normes de
réhabilitation et de construction des
centres d'hébergement d'urgence
madame la ministre prévoyez vous dans
votre plan de lutte contre l'exclusion
de réformer cette règlement de
réglementation adaptée pardon adopté un
peu trop rapidement dans un contexte qui
était tendu lié à l'occupation du canal
saint-martin et de plus ce madame la
ministre êtes vous prête à revoir les
normes de construction et de
réhabilitation afin de différencier le
logement de l'hébergement d'urgence qui
lui par définition est temporaire je
vous remercie de votre réponse
merci madame la ministre madame la
sénatrice vous évoquez dans votre
question plusieurs points la question de
l'insertion la question des
améliorations à l'offre d'hébergement
apportées par les lois porté par madame
boutin et notamment par la loi molle qui
porte à la fois sur l'obligation des
collectivités locales de créer des
places d'hébergement sur la continuité
l'hébergement sur l'humanisation de ses
centres et sur leur ouverture 24 heures
sur 24
et je dois vous dire madame la sénatrice
que nous n'envisageons pas de revenir
sur ces dispositions qui ont constitué
une avancée l'ouverture des centres
toute la journée
la l'obligation d'inconditionnels et oui
d'inconditionnalité de l'accueil qui
permet et qui doit permettre de mettre
en oeuvre de manière réaliste est réel
cette nécessité d'accueillir et de
mettre à l'abri dans un premier temps
les sans abri est une option qui est
partagé par ce gouvernement vous pointer
quelques difficultés notamment celle du
maintien dans des sites d'hébergement de
personnes qui auraient vocation accéder
à un logement pérenne
vous avez sur ce point parfaitement
raison la création de ces 9000 places de
logements accompagnés dé l'année 2013 et
de la mise en oeuvre de la construction
de 150 mille nouveaux logements sociaux
dans le cadre du projet de ce
gouvernement par an vise justement à
ouvrir l'offre de logements accessibles
qui permettront à des personnes ou des
familles qui sont aujourd'hui par faute
de mieux en situation d'hébergement de
pouvoir être accueillis dans de bonnes
conditions
nous développerons également
l'accompagnement dans le logement pour
faciliter l'aide à la pratique locative
pour sécuriser les bailleurs parfois
inquiets de reloger des personnes qui
ont connu des longues périodes à la rue
et nous
qu'on en sorte que les places
d'hébergement soient réservés aux
personnes qui en ont réellement besoin
ces places d'hébergement peuvent être le
fait de centre d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale mais aussi de plus
en plus de maisons relais qui sont des
lieux d'accueil intermédiaire qui
permettra un accompagnement et qui
permettent à des personnes qui étaient
dans une situation de grande précarité
ce qu'on appelle les grands casses et de
la vie de retrouver un lieu d'accueil
digne mais aussi sécurisé avec la
présence d'hôtes sur le site d'accueil
qui rend les choses plus faciles donc la
politique d'hébergement du gouvernement
est une politique globale qui a pour
objectif final l'accès au logement
merci aux dames sénateurs et madame la
ministre
j'apprécie que vous reconnaissiez que
les mesures de l'ancien gouvernement
était bonne dans ce domaine mais
néanmoins votre réponse ne me convainc
pas tout à fait car je vois qu'il ya
toujours une certaine confusion entre le
logement d'urgence et l'hébergement
vous savez bien que les personnes qui
restent en moyenne ou longue durée dans
les centres d'hébergement d'urgence créé
une sorte d'embouteillage puisqu'elle ne
libère pas les places pour celle qui au
contraire sont à la rue et on aurait
davantage besoin
et puis par ailleurs concernant je ne
suis pas sûr que noyer répondu sur les
normes concernant la construction
il s'agit des obligations de 9 m² pour
la réhabilitation et 12 m² pour les
constructions nouvelles et l'a également
cela prive les centres d'hébergement
d'avoir une capacité d'accueil bien
meilleur qu'il ne le peuvent aujourd'hui
merci la parole et à monsieur yves pozzo
di borgo pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants us et
monsieur le président même un ministre
mes chers collègues comme d'autres l'ont
rappelé avant moi cette séance de
questions cribles le trouve une
actualité toute particulière notamment
comme le les grands froids arrivent à
qualité ensuite grâce à cause de vous
grâce à vous madame la ministre qu'à vos
déclarations et à quelques jours sur
l'éventualité des réquisition des locaux
appartenant à l'église en particulier à
paris aurait été un très mal perçue dans
certains milieux à l'autre côté
primesautier apporter un peu de
fraîcheur à la vie politique et j'espère
que cette sortie ne cachait comme peu ne
cachez vous êtes comme que l'agressivité
mais j'espère surtout que ce n'est pas
du tout
que vous trouvez pas un bouc émissaire
faut cacher votre impuissance actualité
enfin car il ya deux jours se tenait la
conférence nationale contre la pauvreté
le premier ministre n'a fait que
rappeler ce qu'il avait déjà annoncé en
novembre sur l'hébergement d'urgence
soit 8000 nouvelles places dans kde mise
pour les demandeurs d'asile
cela paraît bien faible à côté d'un
véritable demande selon le préfet de la
région d'île de france qui sont dépend
de vos services indirectement 40 minutes
et sont financés chaque jour dans la
région ce qui représente 4 170 millions
d'euros
et cette année il y aura quatre centres
de puces de ces sommes là pour 6000
places depuis vingt compris c'est une
somme extrêmement importante madame là
la ministre
et je mets cette somme là en regard des
propos du directeur général de l'adoma
hier dans le parisien
sa structure a engagé un plan de 1,3
milliard d'euros sur huit ans pour
mettre à disposition des méchants pour
l'hébergement d'urgence
la comparaison des chiffres des visions
n'est pas positif pour l'état
madame la ministre vous avez de
contradictions vos logements général or
j'ai l'impression qu'en matière
d'hébergement d'urgence chaque
gouvernement d'ailleurs le vote comme ce
constat n'est précédemment quels qu'ils
soient d'ailleurs réagir pour qu'au coup
pour coup et le nez sur le guidon et qu
aucune vision à long terme existe
réellement
est-ce que vous avez vous des projets
vraiment structurelles pensez vous
réalisez un vrai plan de construction de
mise à disposition progressive
d'hébergement afin d'éviter de toujours
et agir dans l'urgence je suis le pari
je sais qu'il ya des dégâts sont de
compétence au conseil général de paris
ce qui m'intéresse aussi de savoir s'il
ya beaucoup de viagra de compétences
pour d'autres conseils généraux voilà
merci madame cécile duflot
monsieur le sénateur je ne sais si ma
réponse va vous sembler primesautière
néanmoins ce que je souhaitais vous dire
de manière très claire c'est qu'en la
matière et en matière d'hébergement
d'urgence comme je les dis on réponse
aux précédentes question il m'apparaît
plus nécessaire d'être réfléchi et poser
et je voudrais avoir l'occasion dans cet
hémicycle bien plus calme que d'autres
de pouvoir vous indiquer que je
maintiens comme d'ailleurs l'a fait le
premier ministre dans une interview dans
un journal dimanche dernier que la
nécessité de réglisse et
réquisitionnaient des bâtiments vides
vient du fait que d'aucuns n'ont pas
répondu à cet appel c'est à dire de
mettre à disposition de l'état dans le
cadre d'un partenariat
d'une indemnité des bâtiments qui
peuvent être utilisés pour loger ceux
qui en ont besoin nous sommes
aujourd'hui en saturation totale sur
certains territoires du dispositif y
compris des places hivernales c'est à
dire que nous n'avons plus en
ile-de-france notamment la possibilité
de louer aucune chambre d'hôtel pour
accueillir des familles de manière
supplémentaire c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire que tous les mètres carrés
vacants
que ce soit des bâtiments publics de
l'état d'anciennes casernes ou des
bâtiments de bureaux inutilisées mais
aussi les bâtiments des assurances des
banques dont ils sont propriétaires et
je rappelle pour relever du dispositif
de réquisition il faut que ces bâtiments
soient vacants à l'heure actuelle depuis
plus de deux ans on parle et je vous
parle parfois de bâtiments vacants
depuis beaucoup plus années que cela
nous avons décidé de faire en sorte que
tous ces bâtiments puisse être qu'ils
sont susceptibles de réquisition puisse
l'être sans sectarisme sans aucune
volonté primesautière je le dis mais
avec au contraire le sens des
responsabilités et j'aimerais que ceux
qui se sont beaucoup émus de cette
situation
garde une grande part d'émotion pour la
situation de ceux qui ont besoin d'être
logés aujourd'hui dans les mois et les
semaines qui viennent pour vous répondre
très précisément en matière de budget
les efforts consacrés par ce
gouvernement sont significatifs et c'est
justement pour sortir des efforts
supplémentaires de chaque année que nous
avons décidé de re basé le budget 2013
sur le budget consommé 2012 pour ne pas
être en sous dotation permanente comme
l'a constaté la cour des comptes mais
également de lancer un grand plan
structurel de réforme de l'hébergement
d'urgence pour sortir notamment de la
gestion hôtelière qui est très coûteuse
pour les finances publiques et aussi
pour la vider des gens que nous logeons
je pense en particulier aux enfants qui
ne peuvent pas avoir accès à une
scolarisation durable dans ce type
d'hébergement
merci mon cher collègue il veut pozzo di
borgo
oui merci madame la mise votre réponse
on peut sauter
merci mamie forte réponse c'est vrai que
nous annoncer qu'il prostitue rennes
j'imagine que c'est quelque chose que
vous nous présentez règles prochainement
au parlement parce que c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important c'est la
réponse à la question que j'ai posée et
je vous en remercie donc j'attends de
voir quel est le contenu du plan
structurel j'attire votre attention
simplement soyez délégation que votre
ministère avec les conseils généraux
cela vous met pas répondu pour savoir si
vous allez beaucoup de délégations je
sais quel pari vous avez une délégation
et ce qui m'intéresse et avoir des
autres notamment les autres conseils
généraux de la région ile de france
et puis en france évidemment puisqu'ils
ne sont pas uniquement sénateur de paris
voilà alors je sais tu non directement
une 2e
voilà merci la parole est à présent à
notre collègue claude dilain pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
madame la ministre lors de la conférence
nationale contre la pauvreté et pour
l'inclusion sociale
vous avez travaillé avec les
associations sur la question de
l'hébergement d'urgence et d'accès au
logement
les mesures prises à l'issue de cette
conférence vont dans le bon sens en
particulier l'augmentation des
possibilités d'hébergement d'urgence
mais peut-être le plus important de
cette conférence était le retour
symbolique de la notion de solidarité en
parfaite rupture avec les condamnations
inacceptable de l'assistanat qui
prévalait ces dernières ces cinq
dernières années
je souhaiterais insister madame la
ministre sur la localisation de ces
hébergements d'urgence car nous
constatons qu'en même temps que la
pauvreté augmente elle se territorialise
entraînant certains territoires dans la
spécialisation de la pauvreté et de
l'exclusion tout en répondant aux
besoins de cette population nécessaire
il ne faudrait pas que la stratégie des
lieux d'implantation renforce cette
fracture territoriale
on peut regretter par exemple que le
samu social de paris transport trop
souvent des personnes sans abri dans des
hôtels de la seine saint denis dans des
communes très éloignées enclavé est déjà
très pop et risée cette pratique
entraîne évidemment une augmentation des
dépenses sociales pour ces villes
pauvres et où la demande sociale est
déjà très importante
c'est pourquoi madame la ministre je
souhaiterais savoir quelles sont les
réformes
culturel que vous envisagez merci madame
la ministre monsieur le sénateur vous
avez raison sur la question de l'ancrage
territorial et de la répartition de
l'ensemble des places d'accueil
d'hébergement d'urgence mais pas
seulement sur le logement social et nous
nous retrouverons la semaine prochaine
pour voter une nouvelle fois cette loi
qui permettra à l'obligation de 25 % de
logement social dans toutes les communes
mais je crois que c'est au niveau
régional qu'on peut permettre d'aboutir
à un vrai pilotage de la répartition des
places d'hébergement pour vous répondre
très précisément sur l'île de france il
y a un problème spécifique qui est dû au
manque de place tout court c'est à dire
que nous emmenons aujourd'hui
effectivement avec le samu social des
personnes dans les lieux qui existe et
que nous avons pu utiliser
voilà la réalité voilà une partie de la
réponse il n'ya pas de volonté de
répartition différente il ya bien
simplement la réponse à une nécessité
mais des moyens de pilotage
supplémentaires doivent être mises en
place et c'est pourquoi dans le cadre
des arbitrages rendus à l'issue de la
conférence contre la pauvreté mais
surtout vous l'avez noté pour
l'inclusion sociale des moyens pour
renforcer les xiao seront dégagés par ce
que c'est pilotage cette harmonisation
ce travail en réseau des différents des
différents intervenants sur ce secteur
est absolument indispensable il faut
notamment mieux articuler les pda lpd et
les pizzas hachis qui permettront de
faire en sorte justement que cette
articulation entre les différentes
étapes de l'hébergement du logement soit
soit mieux gérer cette nouvelle
articulation sera dans le projet de loi
que j'aurai l'honneur de présenter de
porter devant vous au printemps
enfin au delà de cette première étape il
s'agira aussi de travailler sur des
diagnostics et c'est pourquoi nous avons
décidé avec l'ensemble des 33
associations regroupées dans le
collectif des associations unies de
travailler sur un dispositif de
diagnostic précis sur les territoires
pour préparer le plan de sortie d'hiver
est donc cette réforme structurelle de
l'hébergement et pour aussi travailler
sur une meilleure articulation
territorial qui sera une des priorités
pour l'action de mon ministère pour
l'année 2013
merci merci beaucoup madame la ministre
pour cette réponse qui m'a complètement
satisfait c'est vrai que l'hébergement
d'urgence serait plus simple s'il y
avait beaucoup plus de logements sociaux
donc j'espère madame la ministre dès
lundi soir nous verrons sur tous les
bancs une bonne vraie mobilisation pour
le logement social merci merci je passe
la parole à présent à madame mireille
schurch pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
année après année se pose au début des
jours froids cette cruelle question
comment peut-on laisser dormir dans la
rue des hommes des femmes et des enfants
aujourd'hui près de 80% de sans abri
lors ce qu'ils appellent le 115 se voir
refuser faute de place l'accès à ce
droit essentiel reconnu comme une
liberté fondamentale que celui d'avoir
un toit pour dormir parce qu'une telle
situation heurte profondément notre
pacte républicain
nous avons proposé en conférence des
présidents que cette problématique
fassent l'objet de ces questions cribles
et nous avons donc été entendu vous avez
tenu madame la ministre la conférence
nationale contre la pauvreté le
gouvernement a pris des engagements
forts pour construire huit mille
nouvelles places d'hébergement dont 4000
d'hébergement d'urgence
vous vous êtes engagé à recourir à la
réquisition de logements vides
nous saluons positivement ces efforts le
premier ministre a annoncé mardi 50
millions supplémentaires pour
l'hébergement mais cela ne nous semble
pas suffisant au regard des besoins
criants et vous le savez bien
la question financière reste donc
ouverte centrale et je dirais même ardue
d'autant qu'il faut également financé la
réhabilitation des centres d'hébergement
existants pour qu'il réponde enfin aux
conditions de dignité humaine pourquoi
alors le gouvernement at il refusé la
création d'une taxe sur les bureaux
vacants mesure qui aurait pu qui aurait
permis de contribuer au financement de
ces mesures positives comme vous sans
doute madame la ministre nous le
regrettons de plus en sachant que les
associations estiment à 50 mille le
nombre réel d'expulsion annuel
pourquoi ne pas prendre la décision
politique d'abonder le fonds
d'indemnisation des propriétaires et
interdire les expulsions sans relogement
pour les personnes ne pouvant se
maintenir dans les lieux par leurs
propres moyens
rien de plus simple madame la ministre
il vous suffirait simplement d'inscrire
à l'ordre du jour la proposition de loi
que nous avons déposé en ce sens en
septembre dernier
merci à nos ministres où la parole
madame la sénatrice je tiens en répondre
à votre question a salué le travail
exceptionnel qui a été fait en
préparation de la conférence puisque la
méthode que nous avons choisie est celle
d'une association très grande de tous
les acteurs des collectivités locales
des syndicats qui ont participé à cette
conférence mais aussi évidemment des
acteurs de terrain
à ce titre christophe robert et alain
régnier ont rendu un rapport rendu un
rapport le 3 décembre à portrait riche
que vous devez connaître sûrement et qui
justement vise à la fois faire de
l'année 2013 une année de mobilisation
particulière mais à induire une
transformation en profondeur des modes
d'accueil j'ai parlé l'hébergement mais
aussi de travailler sur la prévention
des expulsions sujet qui vous tient à
coeur et je le dis sujet qui sera parmi
les réformes proposées dans le cadre de
la future loi que je présenterai au
printemps sujet qui a été évoquée
également par le premier ministre par sa
volonté son annonce de mettre en place
une garantie universelle des loyers une
garantie qui permettrait justement
d'identifier dès les premiers mois
boire dès le premier mois d'impayés de
sécuriser les locataires sur la suite de
leur parcours mais également de pouvoir
rassurer les bailleurs et de faire en
sorte de remettre sur le marché des
logements qui sont aujourd'hui vacants
les dispositions coercitives sont utiles
les dispositions incitatives et
notamment de garantir les bailleurs le
sont également pour pouvoir loger des
personnes plus fragiles donc nous allons
travailler sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
l'ensemble de ces questions et de ces
annonces feront l'objet d'un plan qui
sera annoncée précisément un plan
pluriannuel le 22 janvier qui reprendra
l'ensemble de ces éléments et qui
travaillera sur l'ensemble des questions
de l'hébergement du premier hébergement
de l'accueil les personnes aidées
familles les plus fragiles jusqu'au
logement jusqu'à la prévention des
expulsions vous avez raison c'est un
moment décisif pour éviter la mise à la
rue c'est un moment essentiel sur lequel
il existe des filets de sécurité mais
dont on sait qu'une grande partie des
personnes ou des familles ne font pas
appel ou dispositifs existants par
méconnaissance par crainte par angoisse
ou ou simplement par distance donc nous
mettrons en oeuvre tous les dispositifs
dans le cadre de ce plan pluriannuel et
plus largement dans la loi qui
permettront d'anticiper ces situations
et d'y répondre de manière structurelle
ce travail se fera en lien évidemment
étroit avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires et donc avec vous merci
pour la réplique la parole et à madame
brigitte gonthier-maurin du groupe soeur
c'est madame la ministre merci pour vos
précisions je souhaite pour ma part
attirer votre attention sur une
population qui nécessite en matière
d'hébergement d'urgence un intérêt
particulier les femmes victimes de
violences conjugales
c'est au terme d'un cheminement
psychologique douloureuse souvent en
période de crise aiguë que ces femmes
prennent la difficile la difficile
décision de quitter leur conjoint
violent
aussi faut-il être en mesure de leur
proposer très vite une possibilité
d'hébergement des collectivités
territoriales ont pris des initiatives
en ce domaine comme le dispositif un
toit pour elle
en seine saint denis où le dispositif
mis en oeuvre par des communes de la
boucle nord des hauts-de-seine
cela ne peut suffire et l'état doit
prendre sa part
vous nous annoncez que 4000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence seront créés
pendant le quinquennat et que près d'un
tiers d'entre elles sera réservé aux
femmes victimes de violence bien
permettez moi de remarques les femmes
victimes de violence du fait notamment
qu'elle sont souvent accompagnées
d'enfants constituent un public
spécifique
il faut donc imaginer une réponse
d'hébergement d'urgence spécifiques
en second lieu l'hébergement d'urgence
ne doit constituer qu'une solution
transitoire et il est indispensable
d'être en mesure de leur proposer
rapidement des formes d'hébergement qui
soient pérennes
merci
ma parole est à présent à madame aline
archimbaud pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
cher collègue madame la ministre
le droit au logement opposable dida
l'eau a été créée par la loi du 5 mars
2007 instituant le droit au logement
opposable
et pourtant diverses mesures en faveur
de la cohésion sociale la procédure
demande le dépôt d'un dossier auprès de
la commission de médiation qui rend sa
décision dans un délai de trois ou six
mois selon les départements et qui
lorsqu'elle considère que la demande est
prioritaire et quand logement doit être
attribué en urgence transmet la demande
au préfet à compter de la décision de la
commission de médiation le préfet
dispose d'un délai de trois ou six mois
selon les départements
pour faire des propositions de logements
adaptés aux besoins au plan national
près de 300000 recours ont été déposés
depuis 1er janvier 2008 pour un rythme
mensuel de 7000 au premier semestre 2012
et il existe une accumulation de retards
de mise en oeuvre des décisions
favorables qui concerne particulièrement
l'île de france la paca et l'outre-mer
c'est en ile de france le retard cumulé
est estimé à 27 1500 ménages par exemple
au 30 juin 2012
ces retards sont très inquiétants
notamment lorsque les ménages les
ménages sont sous le coup d'une décision
d'expulsion
dans ce contexte je tiens à me féliciter
de la circulaire du 26 octobre dernier
qui oblige les préfets à mettre en
oeuvre leur logement effective des
ménages reconnus prioritaires avant la
date à laquelle leur expulsion pourrait
avoir lieu et qui met en place des aides
supplémentaires afin de réduire le délai
de relogement des ménages ayant accumulé
des dettes locatives
madame la ministre je souhaiterais
savoir de quels moyens concrets vous
allez disposer pour assurer la mise en
oeuvre concrète de la circulaire du 26
octobre dans tous ses aspects y compris
dont le renforcement d'une prévention et
d'un accompagnement en amont des
procédures d'expulsion et de plus
commencera dans ce cadre et pour cette
question met en place le plan de
relogement annoncé mardi
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre vous avez la parole
madame la sénatrice vous pointez un
point très important qui est la mise en
oeuvre du noir d'une loi très important
du noc beaucoup ont salué voté très
largement
la loi qui institue et le droit au
logement opposable mais qui n'a pas mise
en regard les moyens pour construire les
logements sociaux qui auraient été
nécessaires pour répondre à cette loi il
ya aujourd'hui 47 mille ménages en
attente reconnus prioritaires de cette
loi est en attente d'un logement
nous avons donc par une circulaire du 26
octobre à laquelle vous avez fait
référence fait en sorte qu'aucun de ces
ménages ne puisse être expulsés sans
qu'un logement leur soit proposée c'est
une mesure attendue par beaucoup qui
semble assez logique puisque l'état est
responsable du relogement et qu'il y est
obligé par la loi il était incohérent
qu'il recourt à la force publique pour
faire expulser ces ménages cette
circulaire a été appelée est applicable
depuis avant la trêve hivernale elle le
sera je tiens à leur dire devant vous
après nous allons mobiliser l'ensemble
des contingents pour pouvoir permettre
le relogement de ces ménages le premier
ministre annonce et un relogement
prioritaire dans l'année qui vient de 15
mille familles en attente de relogement
il sera effectif par la mobilisation de
l'ensemble des contingents mais je tiens
à dire c'est quinze mille ménages sur
490 mille attributions dans le loge dans
les logements sociaux chaque année donc
si l'ensemble des partenaires qui
concourent au au logement social se
mobilisent il est possible de trouver
une réponse à cette situation
néanmoins cela nous interpelle le comité
de suivi de la loi dalo a remis son
rapport au président de la république en
personne il attirer son attention sur
cette question est la seule réponse qui
vaille est une mobilisation très
importante des acteurs pour leur
logement mais surtout de ceux et celles
qui participeront de la création de
nouvelles offres en matière de logement
vous qu'on vous connaissez nos objectifs
en matière de constructions neuves
il est un chantier qui est devant nous
j'ai évoqué la garantie universelle mais
ce sera un des moyens d'y répondre avec
la hausse de la taxation sur les
logements vacants
cc 2 à 3 millions de logements vacants
aujourd'hui dans notre pays aujourd'hui
disponibles des logements qui sont des
logements et part pour lequel je le dis
la question n'est pas celle de la
réquisition mais au contraire de rendre
les propriétaires en situation de
remettre en location ces logements se
sera là aussi un chantier prioritaire à
augmenter l'offre pour pouvoir répondre
à cette demande criante
si madame la sénatrice aline archimbaud
mais ma musique je vous remercie de
cette réponse enfin qui traduit qui
montrent un réel engagement enfin un
engagement important
je me permettrai simplement d'assister
sur deux points d'une part dans les
moyens mis en oeuvre la nécessité me
semble-t-il de penser à tout ce qui est
prévention en amont
ça suppose bien sûr des moyens mais je
crois que ça évite aussi bien bien des
drames et bien et bien des moyens à
déployer après l'autre point étant
évidemment l'appel à la vigilance de
tous au moment de la fin de la trêve à
partir du 15 mars pour qu' on n'est pas
on n'est pas à nouveau des problèmes qui
s'accumulent je vous remercie
je passe la parole à présent monsieur
pierre charon pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président la ministre mes
chers collègues
la chute des températures ces derniers
jours et encore ce matin pose le
problème de l'hébergement d'urgence de
la façon la plus impérieuse et la plus
pressante
je voudrais que vous éclaire sicié deux
interrogations qui me préoccupe en tant
que sénateur de paris et vice-président
du conseil général mais qui m'interpelle
comme vous dites
en tant que citoyen révolté par le sort
de ceux qui affrontent quotidiennement
le froid dans la rue dont chaque hiver
certains malheureux ne se relève pas il
n'y a pas que l'été vous avez récemment
évoqué la possibilité de réquisition de
locaux vacants en citant maladroitement
l'église et en entretenant des doutes
sur la possibilité de réquisitionner des
logements privés
madame comment expliquer nos
compatriotes que le droit fondamental
qu'est le droit de propriété risque
d'être remis en cause par votre
gouvernement alors même que des
organismes publics dispose de dizaines
de milliers de mètres carrés vacants
à titre d'exemple je voudrais mentionner
les vingt mille mètres carrés vacants
sont les 40000 du 17 boulevard morland
qui appartient à la ville de paris
les exemples de ce type sont nombreux ce
serait l'honneur de votre gouvernement
et la ville de paris de procéder à un
inventaire précis que nous n'aurons pas
nous obtenir de ses propres locaux avant
de menacer les propriétaires privés qui
ont investi dans un appartement
par ailleurs comment expliquer nos
compatriotes les plus fragiles
vivant dans la précarité la plus totale
que leurs demandes restent sans réponse
quand dans le même temps l'état logent
dans des hôtels à 150 euros la nuit des
clandestins qui occupaient une
cathédrale
je fais référence à l'occupation de la
basilique de saint-denis au mois d'août
dernier
ce relogement est une forme de prime à
la délinquance
ici il s'agit d'ailleurs d'une double
transgression de la loi celle de
séjourner illégalement sur notre
territoire et d'occuper illégalement un
édifice religieux
face à cette double infraction d'autres
familles subissent elles une double
peine vivre dans la rue et se voir
discriminés dans l'accès au logement
d'urgence pour bonne conduite
ce constat est d'autant plus choquant
que ces familles qui attendent des
solutions de relogement vivent souvent
dans la plus grande détresse refuse
justement de transgresser les lois de
notre république
pour garder une dignité mis à mal par
leurs conditions de survie
cette situation est grave sur le plan
moral
il ne s'agit bien entendu pas dire archi
zélés souffrance mais quelle que soit la
détresse des populations qui se
retrouvent sur notre territoire
l'accès à l'hébergement d'urgence ne
peut-être facilitée par la transgression
souvent médiatique de la loi au
détriment des plus faibles de nos
concitoyens qui meurent toujours
aujourd'hui dans la rue je vous remercie
merci madame cécile duflot ministre du
logement
monsieur le sénateur je ne
voudrais répondre sur
les éléments les plus précis de votre
question et pas sur les éléments
polémique mais justement il m'appartient
de vous dire que je n'ai entretenu
aucune ambiguïté que je ne retire
évidemment rien ce que j'ai dit puisque
la loi de 1998 vise les personnes
morales exclusivement les personnes
morales pour la procédure de réquisition
mais toutes les personnes morales sans
exception ça c'est un premier élément
que d'aucuns et tenter de s'engouffrer
dans cette question pour fabriquer une
polémique je le constate et je vois que
c'est sur ce plan que vous tentez de
continuer en disant que la réquisition
risquerait de mettre en péril des gens
qu'ils quitteraient leur logement pour
le week end je trouve indécent pour le
coup d'essayer de faire une polémique
sur cette question en revanche je tiens
à vous répondre très précisément le prix
moyen par personne et par nuit d'une
chambre d'hôtel en ile de france c'est
15 euros c'est un budget de 5000 euros
par an et par personne voilà le coût de
l'hébergement
ça n'est pas 150 euros par nuit ça n'est
pas 150 euros par nuit et je pense que
si vous connaissiez précisément mais je
vous invite à le faire je pense que
nombreuses associations seront tout à
fait d'accord pour vous faire visiter
les hôtels dans lesquels ces personnes
sont accueillies vous conviendrez que
les conditions de décence ne sont
parfois pas toujours rempli néanmoins je
les dis nous n'avions jusqu'à lors pas
les moyens de faire autrement
je pense que ce sujet qui est un sujet
qui relève de la dignité humaine la
manière nous avons de considérer les
gens qui sont nos égos et qui
aujourd'hui hommes femmes enfants vivent
parfois à la rue dans des conditions qui
sont absolument inacceptables sont une
question essentielle pour un pays comme
le nôtre qui se revendique qui
revendique au coeur de ces valeurs
l'égalité et la fraternité et non pas la
charité et je considère qu'il est du
devoir de la république de loger de
manière respectable l'ensemble de ses
habitants c'est en tout cas ce à quoi
s'emploie ce gouvernement sans esprit
polémique mais avec une détermination
qui n'a d'égal que la forte que la force
de nos valeurs merci monsieur le sous
pierre charon vous êtes récemment élue à
paris et ou sur la question de vérifier
le prix des chambres d'hôtel mais s'ils
veulent les français pourront le
vérifier aussi à travers la télévision
comme le disent mes collègues aussi et
c'est pas du tout 15 euros la nuit c'est
pas du tout ça je comprends votre gêne
madame non mais c'est à moi de parler ce
n'est pas à vous
vous ne pouvez pas intervenir je vous le
répète c'est l'intérêt des questions
cribles la démocratie existe au sénat ma
proposition est clair avant de faire la
leçon à tout le monde il faut balayer
devant sa porte
la mairie de paris a beaucoup de
logements pour loger les 14000 personnes
qui vivent dans la précarité à paris il
faudrait pour cela un travail de
transparence
ce serait la moindre des choses madame
duflot vous avez voté en tant que
présidente du groupe au conseil régional
en février dernier l'achat d'un hôtel
particulier rue barbet de jouy du xviiie
siècle 19 millions d'euros qui est
destiné au confort des vice présidents
de la région et on l'appelle dans les
couloirs avec malice le château huchon
1800 mètres carrés résultat il est vide
la parole est à monsieur claude
bérit-debat pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre les belges en dedans
d'urgence est plus que jamais un devoir
de solidarité nationale le nombre de
demandeurs augmente toujours plus et
concernent des personnes aux profils
désormais multiple ces personnes ont
besoin d'une aide sociale est de plus en
plus souvent d'un accompagnement médical
si j'ai voulu intervenir aujourd'hui
c'est pour rappeler une réalité la
pauvreté existe également dans les
départements ruraux est lisse et
développe aussi inexorablement en
dordogne le taux d'occupation des sept
structures d'accueil existantes et
proche de 100%
les appels au 115 ont augmenté de 60 %
en trois ans ils ont été multiplié par
deux dans les agglomérations de bergerac
et de perry que déjà les créations de
places prévues en 2010 2011 ne suffisent
plus et l'on ne peut plus répondre à
toutes les demandes à raison d'une offre
qui n'est pas assez adaptée au nouveau
profil des demandeurs
alors que la situation est déjà très
difficile
les crédits de fonctionnement des chrs
ont baissé de 20% en 3 ans obligeant les
collectivités à une dépense qui ne leur
incombe pas à ces difficultés s'ajoutent
que c'est le propre territoire rural à
savoir l'étendue du département et la
répartition déséquilibrée des structures
d'accueil qui sont concentrés entre les
deux grandes agglomérations le
suivi des personnes en pâtit malgré tous
leurs engagements les acteurs sociaux
n'ont pas les moyens de proposer des
solutions qui dépasse justement le cadre
de l'urgence
dans le même temps il faudra accroître
la capacité d'accueil créer des places
d'urgence polyvalente et des places de
stabilisation mais aussi renforcer le
maillage territorial au plus près des
populations concernées
dans ce contexte alors que le premier
ministre annoncée notamment mardi la
conclusion d'un pacte de solidarité qui
prévoit notamment la création de 4000
places en faveur des sans abri
comment l'état peut-il décliner madame
la ministre
son action en s'adaptant aux
spécificités des territoires ruraux qui
sont je le répète soumis aussi à des
problématiques d'urgence et de pauvreté
profonde que l'on ne peut passer sous
silence je vous remercie
laure sinon un ministre monsieur le
sénateur vous avez parfaitement raison
d'attirer l'attention de l'ensemble des
sénateurs sur la question de la pauvreté
mais aussi donc de l'hébergement
d'urgence en milieu rural difficulté qui
est parfois plus sensible puisque du
fait de l'éloignement les et zones
peuvent être plus rapidement saturé je
pense à notamment des régions du
sud-ouest où il y a aujourd'hui des
difficultés d'hébergement particulière
dans des petites villes qui n'en
souffrait pas jusqu alors et que l ont
des difficultés à gérer et plus
importants qui peuvent arriver parfois
ou des nombres importants quand des
familles sont en situation de d'extrême
mal logement
les capacités de mobilisation de places
nouvelles sont aussi plus difficile
parce que les disposer les
disponibilités sont moins grandes
et puis ces territoires sont aussi
parfois marquées par des coûts plus
élevés puisque l'éloignement rend
difficile la mutualisation d'un certain
nombre de services dans ces territoires
se pose également la question du réseau
transports et de l'accès au transport
pour des personnes qui sont pour
l'essentiel en situation d'insertion et
en recherche d'un emploi donc il est
évident que pour moi ces questions non
seulement sont absolument essentielles
mais doivent prendre toute leur place
pour la ministre de l'égalité des
territoires que je suis dans ce débat
que nous allons d'ailleurs avoir dans
quelques heures sur l'égalité des
territoires en matière dax
au service public l'hébergement des
personnes sont logées et l'attention
portée aux plus pauvres en zone rurale
doit être le même que celui qui peut
être fait dans les zones les plus
urbaines évidemment que parfois c'est
plus diffus donc on le voit moins
mais ça n'enlève rien à la réalité de la
situation
donc nous mettrons en oeuvre un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui permettront
d'avoir des places gérées de façon
mutualisée mais qui pourront être
ouvertes en fonction de la demande dans
le cadre de cette réforme de
l'hébergement qui permettra d'avoir pas
seulement de gros dispositif ouvert en
hiver mais bien une répartition de
l'hébergement sur l'ensemble du
territoire de manière pérenne et tout au
long de l'année
ça ne puisse pas le débat mais croyez
monsieur le sénateur à mon réel
engagement pour répondre à la question
de l'hébergement sur l'ensemble du
territoire sur les zones les plus
tendues les plus en difficulté mais sur
celle aussi où c'est moins visible mais
tout aussi indispensable merci alors
monsieur claude bérit-debat pour la
réplique oui merci madame la ministre je
vous remercie de votre réponse mais je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur ce
qui me semble spécifique des territoires
ruraux
ce n'est pas tant en nombre de places
que le problème se pose mais c'est en
termes qualitatifs qualitatif
je crois que dans les deux
agglomérations du département dont je
suis sénateur
ce qu'on souhaite c'est avoir des places
polyvalente on s'aperçoit que c'est des
places qui ont été créés pour des
personnes seules et on est obligé
aujourd'hui d'accueillir des familles et
puis deuxièmement c'est de créer des
places de stabilisation
parce que remettre dans un logement je
dirais classique ou normale des familles
qui sont passées par des hébergements
d'urgence nécessite quelquefois un
apprentissage ce n'est pas aussi simple
que ça et je voudrais appeler aussi
votre attention sur les moyens à mettre
en oeuvre pour que cette coordination
puisse se faire avec un budget de
fonctionnement en hausse pour les
structures qui travaillent dans ce
domaine
merci merci pour la dernière question de
cette séance je passe la parole à madame
catherine procaccia pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre l'hébergement d'urgence est une
compétences totalement régaliennes
pourtant la ddsc souligne que près d'un
tiers des dépenses de co2 la cohésion
sociale sont prises en charge par les
collectivités 13,6 pour cent par les
départements et 8 4% par les communes
mais ceci est une moyenne nationale et
certains sont plus sollicités que
d'autres ainsi en est-il d'un
département que vous connaissez bien le
val de marne qui malgré les mille six
cents lits d'accueil d'urgence et un
budget qui dépasse plus de 11 millions
d'euros doit faire face à des
problématiques spécifiques comme le
nombre croissant de sdf d'origine
étrangère il dépasse de beaucoup le taux
moyen de 29 % de l'insee ainsi 40% des
mères isolées accueillis dans le cadre
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance sont issus
de l'immigration africaine est en
situation irrégulière selon des
déclarations du conseil général devant
l'assemblée nationale dans un rapport de
janvier 2012
quant aux communes elles ont elles aussi
à la charge à leur char l'aide sociale
la gratuité des cantines
madame la ministre malgré le poids des
dépenses sociales ne peut s'accroître
indéfiniment pour nos collectivités
comment l'état compte il empêcher que
l'hébergement d'urgence ne fasse
exploser leur budget c'est ma première
question je veux aussi attirer votre
attention sur les deux sens sans abri du
bois de vincennes
ils vivent dans des tentes dans des
conditions d'hygiène déplorables dans la
plus grande misère sociale
soulevant à la fois des problèmes de
santé et d'insécurité les associations
mènent un repérage géographique
difficile et certains tentent de trouver
des solutions au froid de l'hiver comme
l'an passé mon collègue christian cambon
qui a réussi à les inclure dans les
hôpitaux de saint maurice dont ce n'est
quand même pas la vocation
madame la ministre allez vous continuer
à accepter le développement de ces
campements dans le bois de vincennes
enfin j'aimerais savoir pourquoi le
gouvernement ne consultent pas les élus
quand il prend des décisions
d'hébergement d'urgence ainsi à ivry sur
seine
le maire n'a pas été consultés lorsque
vous avez réquisitionné une ancienne
maternité et un foyer sncf pour les sans
abri vos prédécesseurs ont pas fait
mieux
dès lors ce qu'ils ont installé des
df dans le fort de nogent les maires
sont pourtant très attentifs à ces
problématiques et j'espère qu'il ne
continuera pas nous ne continuerons pas
être exclues de ces processus merci
madame la ministre cécile duflot
ministre du logement
madame la sénatrice je vais vous
répondre en deux points d'abord sur la
situation particulière du bois de
vincennes qui est préoccupante tant en
été qu'en hiver mais qu'il devient
évidemment de manière très importante
quand le froid devient si vif qu'il peut
mettre physiquement en péril les gens
qui y vivent aujourd'hui les personnes
qui jouent dans le bois de vincennes
sont suivis par l'état et la ville de
paris qui cofinance une maraude qui est
géré par emmaüs cette maraude est
chargée spécifiquement de
l'accompagnement et du suivi des
personnes qui vivent dans le bois le
dernier point de situation au 10
décembre fait état de la présence de 118
personnes
vous évoquez deux sens où c'était le
chiffre des personnes cet été on pense
que sur les 180 personnes qui avaient
été répertoriés le 12 novembre
quarante-sept personnes repérées comme
étant les plus fragiles et qu'ils ont
acceptées ont été orientées notamment
vers des dispositifs qui venait de
s'ouvrir vous avez évoqué le fort de
nogent c'est le cas d'un lieu qui est
apprécié par un certain nombre de sdf
qui acceptent de s'y rendre alors qu'ils
refusent parfois des propositions
d'hébergement et la redoute de gravelle
des possibilités et des dispositifs de
réorientation sont toujours en cours le
dispositif de maraude renforcée se
poursuit et nous faisons en sorte avec
les maraudes emmaüs avec l'action des
services de la ville et avec le samu
social de paris de suivre au plus près
ces personnes je voudrais vous répondre
sans pause sans rentrer dans les détails
sur l'origine des personnes qui sont pas
accueillis vous avez vous il a été
évoqué tout à l'heure le principe
d'inconditionnalité de l'accueil ce
principe est un principe essentiel en
particulier vis-à-vis de jeunes femmes
vous l'avez dit qu'ils ont des enfants
qui sont pour l'essentiel dans ses
foyers maternelle né sur le territoire
français sur la question des dépenses
sociales un travail est en cours avec
l'association des départements de france
le détail conscient du poids que cela
représente dans leur budget je dois dire
qu'en matière d'hébergement d'urgence et
l'état qui assume l'essentiel des
dépenses nécessaires pour votre dernier
point sur l'association des élus il n'a
pas été réquisitionnée la maternité jean
rostand à ivry
elle a été ouverte dans le cadre d'un
partenariat avec l'assistance publique
pour ce qui est du foyer de l'ancien
foyer cheminots mise à disposition de la
sncf
le maire d'ivry en a été un vrai averti
puisque son adjointe en charge des
questions sociales étaient présentes au
moment où je me suis rendu avec le
président de la sncf nous travaillons
autant que faire se peut avec les élus
je veux dire parfois que nous faisons
indépendamment des couleurs politiques
face à quelques résistances et qui me
semble nécessaire que l'état assume en
la matière comme vous l'avez dit son
pouvoir régalien de loger ceux et celles
qui en ont besoin
merci madame procos heures merci madame
la ministre sur le bois de vincennes
effectivement la comptabilisation et je
me réjouis qu'il n'y ait que 100
personnes mais il ya encore plus de 110
personnes qui sont dans le bois dans des
tentes dans des conditions qui sont sans
doute pire encore que que dans les
squats et je pense que le rôle de l'état
de la ville de paris ou de la préfecture
je ne sais tu qui se serait d'empêcher
que les gens continuent à s'installer
si même en ce moment il n'y a pas de
camps de roms on a aussi eu des camps de
roms
au milieu du bois etc des personnes qui
n'ont ni eau qui n'ont vraiment accès à
rien vous me parlez de l'état assume
l'essentiel mais les communes et les
départements assume encore une bonne
partie et le nombre de ces personnes ne
fait qu'augmenter
quand vous ne dites des enfants nés du
territoire j'assure que dans le
val-de-marne et heureusement et bien on
ne regarde pas si des enfants sont nés
en france ou s'ils sont nés à l'étranger
et que et qu on les héberge
donc ce n'est pas une question d'origine
mais c'est une question de coût merci
merci mes chers collègues c'est la fin
de cette séance de questions cribles si
vous souhaitez la revoir notre site
internet publicsenat.fr prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
parlementaire c'est à 19h avec le
journal présenté ce soir par michel
grossiord très bonne fin de journée à
tous